nous sommes dans la crise climatique et
nous allons nous battre pour avoir le
dernier mot sur l'environnement au
québec le parti québécois propose
d'établir l'indépendance du québec en
matière d'environnement d'adopter une
loi qui donnerait au québec le dernier
mot même face au fédéral dès qu'une
décision environnementale concerne le
territoire québécois
ce n'est pas vrai que ottawa va décider
pour nous où va passer un pipeline
il faut s'attendre à tout un débat
juridique d'abord l'environnement ce
n'est pas un champ de compétence
reconnue dans la constitution
en 1867 les pères de la constitution ne
se souciait pas autant d'environnements
par contre le concept de protection
d'environnement s'invite dans plusieurs
champs de compétences qui sont parfois
strictement la juridiction fédérale
comme les pipeline qui traverse
plusieurs provinces les réserves
autochtones les pêches les chemins de
fer les aéroports le transport maritime
les ports ecce terra
prenons l'exemple récent du port de
québec la compagnie im tti a fait
construire sept réservoirs de produits
chimiques et le gouvernement du québec
s'y opposer en disant que le projet
devait d'abord être soumis aux
évaluations environnementales du québec
un juge a tranché comme les réservoirs
de la compagnie sont sur une propriété
fédérale c'est la loi canadienne qui
prime
québec a porté la décision en appel
d'ailleurs il y a actuellement plusieurs
litiges devant les tribunaux où
s'affrontent les notions de protection
d'environnement et de compétence
gouvernementale
est ce qu'une loi établissant
l'indépendance la primauté du québec en
matière d'environnement pourrait
clarifier tout ça est ce que nous disent
les experts c'est que le projet de loi
du vécu va plutôt entraîné un long débat
juridique et risque fort d'être déclarée
inconstitutionnelle
[Musique]